what's been your uh for you man like you
know who who some of the uh outside of
you you mentioned the Spanish [ __ ]
earlier but like what's the music you're
listening to on the hip-hop side
nowadays like what's the last album you
[ __ ] with
last time I'm gonna [ __ ] with
a whole lot of red
really I'm cardiac that was like two
years ago yeah that was the last time
huh yeah
I think that [ __ ] is one of the worst
bodies of work I've ever heard in my
life
I still like it when I listen to Playboy
cardi I I in my head I'm like [ __ ] he's
the one artist
like when I listen to your [ __ ] I got it
I was like this shit's hard Playboy card
is [ __ ] bruh I'm out it's not for me I
like it I'm an old head
whatever it is that [ __ ] they could keep
it I saw him performing at running loud
that [ __ ] was terrible
he sounded like he was [ __ ] seancing
demons on stage it was it was wild bro
to me bro gotta got a good stage
performance like yeah I mean sure like
if you just like someone screaming yeah
I don't know man maybe I'm tripping but
hey shout out to cardi so that's your
last that was like two years ago so
there's been nothing else that's dropped
in the last two years huh
Lucy just dropped the tape too it was
easy
also on the SoundCloud
not Rushmore who else is up there with
you
it's you and Uzi and then filling the
rest X
who do you think is on there
who else you put on there
use the X probably
I don't know man there was like
trying to think 2017 2018.
what do you think Hmm
I'll definitely put Yak up there
Kodak you think SoundCloud
I I see I was living in Tampa when he
started to pop so I kind of saw him from
like a street level like Kodak Kodak is
definitely
but he's on the Mount Rushmore like oh
he's on the Mount Rushmore the last like
[ __ ] five years for sure yeah that's
fair